our latest survey from last quarter of
last year reveals actually the skills
crisis as widened to include other
trades such as plasterers roofers
electricians right across the board
which is obviously having an impact on
the construction industry and posing a
problem for small construction companies
because costs are going up what's behind
that is it that there's a lack of supply
or is it that demand has increased in
supplies and there to cope with it well
it's both there has been a strong demand
since the recession and that hasn't
leveled off since the EU referendum and
during the last recession we lost about
400,000 people from the construction
sector and those people haven't come
back so there is a serious shortage of
skilled labor which are still trying to
address is that the model these skilled
workers are actually retiring and
they're not being replaced by younger
people is a problem with recruitment
into the industry there is a point in
terms of image attracting young people
to come into the building industry and
losing a lot of skilled people towards
the end of their careers what we need to
be doing of course is promoting
construction as an attractive career in
terms of encouraging young people to
come into the industry yet presumably
these are quite well paid jobs on the
whole I mean how much does the average
pilaster get paid well it varies across
the country certainly in London and
southeast we know bricklayers earning
60,000 pounds because there's such a
shortage of bricklayers that's were only
increased now right across the building
trade so good opportunity there for
young people wanting to come into the
building industry to earn good money
what proportion of people working in the
industry of EU workers who might not
necessarily be able to work in the
industry and future yes that's
interesting overall it's about 12%
across the UK or though it's much higher
in london and the south-east and
obviously that's going to have an impact
if there's going to be any restriction
on labor movement coming into the UK
which does pose another problem at a
time where we've got a serious skills
crisis which is why we need to be
thinking about in terms of vocational
training but in the short term I think
the government is going to have to look
at this very seriously and and make sure
that we're allowing construction workers
to come into the UK otherwise we won't
be able to build the homes that the
government has said that are desperately
needed but shouldn't the industry be
doing more to train people up itself
well we are in the industry we're now
promoting the value of apprenticeships
we're trying to encourage more employers
to take on apprentices the government is
working with us I mean there's a
recognition that we need to get more
people into the building industry and we
need to develop quality apprenticeships
is it the case then that the industry
has been falling back on migrant labor
when it could have been doing more
previously well certainly this happened
in the 1990s after the the 98 late 1980s
recession we relied very much on migrant
labor coming from Europe we can't rely
on that anymore we need to actually
train people in this country to come
into the building industry it's a
serious wake-up call but it's come at
the worst possible time and the
shortages to which you're referring are
they national or are they more marked in
certain parts of the country over others
well it's national but certainly in
London societies where there's an acute
demand for building work there is a
serious shortage which is why we've been
heavily reliant on EU labor what's the
impact of this likely to be on inflation
what is it likely to be in terms of the
cost of building new homes well if labor
is going to go up that means the cost of
projects is going to increase which
means homes when we've got a desperate
shortages are likely to go up so this
will have an impact on inflation but
anecdotally our house builders put
passing on these costs to home buyers at
the moment or are they absorbing the hid
themselves I think at the moment
particularly the SME to probably sort of
trying to absorb the cost but that they
won't be able to do that in the the
coming year or so so those costs will
translate to the consumer which is bad
news at a time when house prices that
are probably at an all-time high